et on avait piégé notre grand patron le
président en titre en capitaux et j'ai
un cadeau à lui faire ce soir parce que
franck a plutôt regardé on l'avait pg il
ya quelques semaines avec la banda syfy
regardez regardez vous on va retourner
là bas l'année prochaine gérald brice
viret patron du groupe canal
voilà c'est le directeur des pointes de
tout le groupe canal+ et franck appelé
tôt le président de ses 8
merci les chéris merci merci de bien
comme ça voilà
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
verser à la banque
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
voilà mes chéris et regardez c'est
l'élégance c'est l'élégance à la
française frank a très tôt il est
toujours très élégant notre président et
j'ai décidé voilà de bien surprendre les
frais de pressing à ma charge et il
était revenue aujourd'hui dans le studio
pour que je le mets redonne son costume
il est là il ya an lorsqu'il est bien
voilà mon chéri merci vous double
d'avant frérot ces adorables
merci monsieur regret parce que c'est
alors il voulait pas il est tout propre
il est tout propre et toi mon chéri
franck appelé tout je vais dire franck
toi tu as eu de cet été bien tu es bien
lotis il ya du président en ce moment
les émissions sont tellement drôle
c'est vrai ah oui non mais j'adore ce c
comptant des émissions mais je suis très
content des émissions alors je voudrais
dire quelque chose parce que franck mon
chéri tu as vu ce qui arrive aux
chroniqueurs total de la crème ouais et
ils ont des chocolats
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
oui
c'est ici